what's popping Rockstars it's me Mt and
everybody has been wondering just what
this weird ringed glowing light source
of yellow light that Scotland is trying
to shoot or get to in the quantumania
trailer well I think I have an idea
because I think that this glowing light
source could be something from the
comics called the Enigma Force and this
is really important during the Big Bang
at the beginning of time when the
primordial God of Darkness null was born
nose opposite the God of Light was also
born and this God of Light was called
the Enigma Force and the Enigma Force is
literally the cosmic force in the Marvel
universe that binds all the atoms of the
universe together it is literally the
reason why our universe of molecules
just doesn't fall apart and in the
comics there was a microverse Explorer
by the name of Arcturus ran who came
into contact with this energy and was
able to do crazy cool things like use
telepathy and at some points manipulate
matter which is why I feel like Janet
Van Dyne was able to heal ghost of her
molecular disequilibrium using Quantum
energy because Quantum energy in the
Enigma Force are the same thing